فاطمه لنشاهد كما تشاهدين فرق الانتقاد ما
زالت موجوده وهناك ايضا جميع الادوات
اللازمه لهذه العمليات
اذا كم شخص حتى الان بالاسعار
فتاتين شخصين واحده 11 سنه والثانيه تسع
سنوات بقيت الثالثه ما زالت الان تحت
الانقاض
يعني لم نعرف بصراحه ان كان والدهم ام لا
يبدو انه اما والدهم او شقيقهم
كما تشاهدين الان بالصوره فاطمه ما زالت
تحاول فلك الانقاذ يعني الوصول الى الفتاه
الان فاطمه يطلبون من الصمت ونحن يعني
الطريقه المحتمده
نعم
اذا نتابع معكم مشاهدينا صور مباشره من
قهرمان مرعش عبر شاشه الكاميرا لعمليه
انقاذ تم انتشار من خلالها فتاتين وتم
نقلهم الى الاسعاف مع الشخص على ما يبدو
انهم انه قريب لهم لا نعلم ان كان اباهم
ام اخاهم احد اقربائهم ولكن الان يبدو ان
هناك شخص ثالث
وتتم الان عمليه الصمت ليتمكنوا من سماع
اي صوت من تحت الانقاظ
انقاذ الاشخاص تحت لانهم يعني يذكر بان
هناك فتاتان تم انقاذهم الان ولكن هناك
ايضا شخص ثالث ينتظرينه تحت الانقاض على
امل ان يتمكنوا من انقاذ الشخص الثالث من
تحت الانقاض اذا هناك صمت كامل فقط نعود
الى شخص نود ان نسالهم بناتك ام
اختي وجوزها واحده ماتوا ثلاثه تضلوا هذول
بنات اختك
البنت اللي ضلت كم عمرها اللي ضل عمرها
سبع سنين او ثمانيه
شكرا شكرا
طلبوا منا المغادره
بس سنعود الى عمليات الانقاذ
طبعا فاطمه كما تشاهدين ما زالت يعني
تتواصل الجهود للوصول الى الفتاه الثالثه
وكما علمنا انها عمرها سبع سنوات يعني
نستطيع ان نلاحظ ان هناك الحياه
نعم يعني حسب ما علمنا من خل البنات بانها
على قيد الحياه اكدوا له انها على قيد
الحياه وما زالوا حتى اللحظه يحاولون
الوصول اليها